welcome back next tuesday marks 25 years  since hip-hop legend tupac was gunned  down here in las vegas tupac was only 25  years old when he was murdered he was  shot while riding in a car at the  intersection of koval in flamingo  no one has ever been arrested the mob  museum is holding a special program  tonight looking back at the stars life  and death  it's hard to believe you know that it's  been that long but  this shooting that happened just off the  las vegas strip was one of the biggest  crimes that happened in las vegas  history  panelists will include hip-hop legend  chuck d and others the event is sold out  though we'll cover it for you here on 8  news now